así
cómo les fue encontraron cómo extender
el algoritmo de castelló a 4 puntos no
es tan fácil así que no se preocupen si
tuvieron problemas esto es algo que
llego de castelló primero usamos
interpolación lineal junto con el
parámetro t para encontrar un punto en
cada uno de los tres segmentos ahora
tenemos un polígono de tres puntos justo
como la hoja de pasto como antes hay que
encontrar un punto en cada uno de los
segmentos nuevos usando interpolación
lineal y el mismo valor t ahora tenemos
un polígono de dos puntos o una línea
encontramos un punto en esa línea usando
una vez más interpolación lineal y
conforme variamos el parámetro t este
punto final traza nuestra curva
estas son el tipo de curvas que usamos
normalmente para controlar el movimiento
de nuestros personajes cuando los
animamos usamos algo llamado editor de
curvas que nos permite manipular los
puntos de control de estas curvas para
lograr movimientos naturales entre poses
este es el editor de curvas que usamos
en pixar entre cada pose clave hay una
curva de ciega
también agrupamos los segmentos
adyacentes así mantienen la pendiente de
la curva a través del cuadro principal
esto evita sacudidas repentinas en el
movimiento pueden usar el siguiente
ejercicio interactivo para obtener un
poco de experiencia con las curvas de
decir que tienen tres cuatro o incluso
más puntos